This video was made possible by CuriosityStream.
Sign up for the CuriosityStream/Nebula bundle
deal at CuriosityStream.com/Wendover to watch
an exclusive companion video diving deeper
into this video’s subject.
The first thing to know about the art market
is that it’s tiny.
Despite its prominence in cinema, literature,
and the news, the majority of the market is
composed of a small collection of dealers
and auctioneers catering to an exclusive list
of ultra-rich clientele.
Each year, on average, $61.9 billion of art
is sold.
$61.9 billion is a big number, but not in
context.
$61.9 billion is what Walmart, for example,
sells in just 41 days.
The global market of tomatoes generates $190
billion in annual sales—three times as much
as art.
There are single companies with greater annual
sales that you probably haven’t even heard
of: AXA, the Centene Corporation, Exor, the
McKesson Corporation—the entire art market
is smaller than each of these.
The second thing to know about the art market
is that it’s extraordinarily consolidated.
Over the past decade, 82% of sales, by value,
were made in the US, UK, or greater China.
That’s to say, the global art market is
a phenomenon largely restricted to New York,
London, and Hong Kong.
But the consolidation doesn’t end there.
43% of art dealers, nearly half, had fewer
than 20 unique buyers in 2020.
Their sale and buyer numbers can be as limited
as those of realtors, which starts to make
sense when comparing the sale prices of the
two markets.
Unsurprisingly, this means that power in the
industry is extraordinarily concentrated too.
One study found that 30% of solo exhibitions
at museums in the US, considered the hallmark
of success, featured artists represented by
one of just five galleries.
Once you move into the upper echelons of the
industry, however, the concentration intensifies.
During the studied period, eleven out of twelve
solo exhibitions at the Guggenheim, considered
one of the world’s preeminent art museums,
presented artists represented by one of the
same five galleries.
So, to summarize, the key features of this
market are that it is small and concentrated—without
knowing anything more, an economist could
tell you that this is, theoretically, a market
ripe for exploitation and corruption.
But that’s just theory.
To understand where the malpractice occurs,
one must first understand the practice—how
art sales work.
Nearly three decades ago, in 1994, artist
Roy Lichtenstein put on one of the last solo
shows of his career.
For this, he created a series of nude portraits—a
novel subject for Lichtenstein, presented
in his archetypical style.
Now, in order to translate his work into income,
Lichtenstein partnered with the Leo Castelli
Gallery.
This was no surprise, as Castelli and his
gallery had been long-time partners of the
pop-art icon.
Three decades prior, Castelli had presented
Lichtenstein’s first-ever one-man show.
The two had formed a professional relationship
over the years prior while Lichtenstein worked
as an assistant art professor at Rutgers University
and Castelli believed his work could be a
commercial success.
He was, of course, correct, as every single
piece was sold prior to the show’s opening.
This skyrocketed Lichtenstein’s career.
Overnight, he was transformed from, essentially,
a hobbyist, into an internationally-known,
commercially-successful, professional artist.
So, for all intents and purposes, Castelli
made Lichtenstein.
Therefore, Lichtenstein stuck with Castelli
throughout his career, which brought him to
that 1994 exhibition—entitled “Nudes:
9 Color Relief Prints.”
As is common in the high-end art world, it’s
difficult to precisely trace the ownership
history of given works, but we know that one
of the pieces, Nude with Joyous Painting,
was sold by the Castelli Gallery to a private
collector in New York, then sold by the James
Goodman Gallery to a private collector in
Detroit, before it was purchased by an unknown,
new owner.
That new owner then decided, in 2020, to sell
the painting.
Therefore, they contacted Christie’s.
Now, Christie’s and it’s primary competitor,
Sotheby’s, are the big movers and shakers
in the art market.
They’re auction houses, and facilitate the
sale of much of the world’s most expensive
art.
Of the ten highest priced sales in 2020, eight
occurred at either Christie’s or Sotheby’s.
Their process starts with an appraisal.
Each auction house employs in-house experts
who determine what they believe a piece will
sell for, and present a range—a lower number
and a higher number.
Then, assuming they want to move forward,
the auction house and seller will mutually
agree to a reserve price—a number equal
to or less than the lower range of the estimate,
under which they will not sell the piece,
even if an offer is submitted.
Typically, with higher-end sales, however,
the auction house will persuade the seller
to use their services by guaranteeing the
sale—agreeing to purchase the artwork themselves
for the lower end of the estimate, even if
no bids are submitted.
On the other end of the spectrum, the auction
house takes a 2% fee if a piece of artwork
is sold above the upper estimate to incentivize
performance, although this is often waived
in contract negotiations with the seller.
The seller also pays a percentage fee, supposedly
as much as 10% for lower-priced works, and
as low as 2% for higher-priced works, although
official numbers are not published and are
highly subject to negotiation as auction houses
are eager to bring in sellers.
The bulk of the auction house’s money is
made from the buyer.
They pay, on top of the final sale price,
a percentage fee.
At most Christie’s auction houses, it’s
25% on sales up to $600,000, 20% for sales
up to $6,000,000, then 14.5% on sales above
that number.
This is all to say, when Christie’s or Sotheby’s
gets their hands on the kind of artwork that
lists for 10s of millions of dollars, they
are highly, highly financially motivated to
make the sale.
Roy Lichtenstein’s Nude with Joyous Painting
falls into this category.
A deceased, highly commercially successful
artist; a break-from-style piece, created
towards the end of its artist’s career—there
was a lot going for this painting, and Christie’s
knew it.
Therefore, they scheduled its auction to take
place at one of their top events of the year.
Under the constraints of the COVID-19 pandemic,
the auction house organized a new format for
one of 2020’s biggest auctions.
While each of their auctions typically occur
under the banner of one of their locations,
their Hong Kong, Paris, London, and New York
auction houses teamed up to run a simultaneous,
global, live-streamed auction.
Now, of the 79 lots put up for auction, the
absolute least expensive was a piece by Matthew
Wong appraised between $60,000 and $80,000.
Most were well into the millions, and this
was by design.
Christie’s, Sotheby’s, and other auction
houses will aggregate their highest-priced
works together into a few yearly auctions,
so that they can turn them into can’t miss
events for the art world.
Their job is essentially the marketing—they’re
trying to build anticipation and excitement
for the sale of a given piece—so they’ll
spend the months prior working their catalogue
of buyers, talking to the press, and exhibiting
works all around the world.
Then, after almost all of the work is completed,
the night of the auction arrives.
In this case, the event started with Hong
Kong.
Their auctioneer, live-streamed to the world,
sold nine relatively lower-priced works before
passing the torch to Paris, from where 15
higher priced lots were auctioned.
Then, it moved onto London, where hammer prices
crept further and further into the millions,
and finally, it was New York’s turn.
Saving the best for last, all of the true
headliners were auctioned from New York.
This included Picasso’s, Basquiat’s, Calder’s,
O’Keeffe’s, Warhol’s, and, of course,
the Lichtenstein.
Bidding opened on Nude with Joyous Painting
at $20 million.
That was quickly pushed up to 22, 26, 28,
then 29 million dollars.
Two anonymous bidders from New York, aided
by phone-laden representatives at the auction
house, pushed the price up by half-million
increments to 36, until a buyer from Hong
Kong swooped in and bid $37 million.
One of the New York bidders responded with
$38 million, then the other New York bidder
came back with 38.2.
It went to 38.5, 39, 39.5, 40, before the
Hong Kong buyer bid $40.5 million, which met
no response, and the auctioneer’s hammer
came down on what would become the third highest-priced
art sale of the year.
With fees, the buyer ended up paying $46,242,500,
meaning Christie’s netted at least $5,742,500
from the 10 minute and 14 second long auction.
Across the evening, though, some $421 million
of art was sold.
That means this one, four-hour event, and
its 79 lots, accounted for almost a full percent
of the entire world’s art sales in 2020,
by value, and that Christie’s, as a company,
earned upwards of $60 million.
So… where’s the problem?
So far, most of this process probably seems
above-board—its just a collection of wealthy
people buying and selling expensive art through
a few exclusive auction houses.
Well, its not so much the process itself,
but what it enables.
Most of the issues arise out of a simple truth—art
does not have intrinsic value.
Say you stopped by a thrift store, saw this
painting on the wall, and it had no label,
no price tag, no information at all beyond
the piece itself.
How much would you pay for it?
Some would only spare twenty or thirty dollars,
while others, impressed by its intricacy and
age, might pay a couple hundred dollars for
it.
This is roughly what happened in 1958 when
it was presented at a small auction in London
as a poorly-maintained copy of a lost work
by Leonardo Da Vinci, and sold for £45 to
Minnie and Warren Kuntz.
The couple carried the painting with them
to Southampton, then boarded a ship bound
for Houston to return from their European
vacation.
In 1987, the artwork was inherited by Kuntz’s
nephew, Basil Clovis Hendry, who hung it in
his Baton Rouge, Louisiana home until his
death in 2004.
His daughter, Susan Hendry Tureau, brought
the work and much of the rest of her father’s
estate to the New Orleans Auction Gallery,
where it was listed with a sale estimate of
$1,200 to $1,800.
It was bought for an unknown amount less than
$10,000 by a pair of art dealers, Alexander
Parrish and Robert Simon, who had a long-shot
hunch that it could be worth far more than
that.
They therefore hired a paintings conservator
from NYU to restore the work, and as part
of her process, she took infrared photographs
of the piece to be able to see through the
layers of paint.
This unearthed the lowest layer, which included
the very first strokes—the ones the artist
took to outline the general composition of
the painting.
These first strokes largely matched up with
the final product, except for here—the thumb.
They outlined the thumb in a straight position,
rather than the curved shape seen in all known
copies of the lost Da Vinci painting.
It seemed that the artist changed their mind,
which would make no sense when copying a painting.
These few, hidden strokes served as a crucial,
initial piece of evidence that this might
be the original Salvator Mundi, painted by
Leonardo Da Vinci himself.
Therefore, Parrish and Simon spent the better
part of the next five years travelling around,
showing the piece to experts and curators,
garnering support for their theory.
In 2011, they attained definitive validation:
London’s National Gallery exhibited the
Salvator Mundi and the name on the label read
Leonardo Da Vinci.
The value instantly skyrocketed.
Parrish and Simon sold the piece to another
dealer for $80 million, who immediately sold
it to a Russian collector for $127 million,
who then brought the piece to auction.
Only the 24th known painting widely attributed
to Da Vinci, and one of only two not held
by a museum, this was sure to fetch an eye-popping
price.
After a world tour of exhibitions, Leonardo’s
Salvator Mundi was sold by Christie’s New
York for $450,312,500 to Saudi Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman—an all-time record price
for the sale of a piece of art.
Prior to the recognition by top museums that
this piece was, in fact, a Da Vinci, the value
was in the low thousands.
After, it was in the hundreds of millions.
That’s to say, art has no intrinsic value.
The value for what Christie’s, Sotheby’s,
or other top auction houses sell is all in
who painted it, who owned it, and who wants
it.
An uninformed person can look at a car, or
a plate of food, or a house and guess with
some accuracy what it’s worth, but that’s
not the case with art.
Nearly all of the value is invisible, because
the value is simply what other people are
willing to pay.
Now, here’s the question: would you genuinely
believe that if you had bought that dilapidated
portrait of Jesus at the estate auction in
New Orleans, you could have successfully convinced
the National Gallery in London that it was
a true Da Vinci?
Do you believe that if, back in 1960, Roy
Lichtenstein had met you, instead of Castelli,
you could have successfully convinced enough
people of the artist’s future prospects
to sell out his first show prior to opening?
Any answer but no is arrogant.
Value in the art world is defined by an incredibly
small number of gatekeepers—the curators,
gallery owners, and auctioneers.
So, to summarize, the art world is an incredibly
small, incredibly consolidated market where
prices are almost entirely subjective.
These three factors combined mean that, properly
executed, sellers can decide what prices are.
Between 2005 and 2013, one fourth of all Andy
Warhol works put up up for auction were bought
by a single man: Jose Mugrabi.
Now, Mugrabi owns over 800 Warhol artworks
in total, representing close to a billion
dollars in value, at least on paper.
Therefore, Mugrabi is highly, highly invested
in making sure that the Warhol market stays
hot.
Now, there is, of course, a reason why in
more traditional markets, monopolies and oligopolies
are disallowed: when power is too concentrated,
a single player can influence the entire market
to their own benefit.
That’s exactly what Mugrabi does: whenever
a Warhol is up for sale at auction, he’ll
be there.
Often, Mugrabi will be one of the first to
bid, and will work to push up prices with
his early offers.
Mugrabi is more than willing to strategically
overpay for a Warhol work, because he knows
that it’ll be worth it.
That’s because auctions act as the only
publicly-available index of art prices.
When one private individual sells artwork
to another private individual, the price is
not public-knowledge.
When one private individual sells artwork
at auction, the price is public-knowledge.
So, that means that Mugrabi is willing to
go to an auction and bid copiously, regardless
of actual market value.
Either he’ll have pushed up the price for
another bidder, which is good for him, or
he’ll have overpaid for the art, which is
still good for him.
That’s because either way, the fact that
a Warhol work sold for a good price and the
world knows it pushes up the hypothetical
value of the rest of his Warhol pieces, which
he can then sell for more in private.
What’s more, this manner of market manipulation
is entirely legal.
Collectors will chose a niche, and then dominate
it.
Plus, given the small size of the high-end
art market, Mugrabi almost certainly knows
all the other top Warhol collectors, and collectively,
they realize that if one of them sells a piece
publicly for a bad price, it’ll hurt all
of their portfolio values, so an informal
social cabal arises that further influences
the market and artificially inflates values.
However, this is only the tip of the iceberg.
The same market conditions that enable Mugrabi’s
influence mean that collusion and corruption
are confoundingly easy.
There isn't one, blockbuster scam at the center
of the art market.
Rather, it’s a market composed of scams.
For example, counterintuitively, wealthy individuals
can turn a profit by donating art.
It’s rather simple: in the US, when one
donates artwork to a non-profit museum, they
get a tax-write off.
That’s to say, if someone donates a painting
worth $10 million, they don’t have to pay
taxes on $10 million of income which, in theory,
would save them about $4 million.
Of course, given the difficulties in determining
art’s worth, the IRS requires expensive
artwork to be professionally appraised prior
to a write-off.
Considering all the aforementioned market
conditions, though, it’s not tough to manipulate
an appraisal to go one’s way.
Of the hundreds of thousands of artworks donated
each year, the IRS audits only a couple hundred,
but even those few paint a stark picture.
In 2018 and 2019, about a third of audited
artwork was found to be over valued in its
appraisal by an average of 38%.
In fact, overall, only 42% of artwork was
found to have been appraised correctly, in
part thanks to the competing pressure for
some to undervalue their work when its received
through inheritance, in order to reduce the
estate taxes paid upon transfer of ownership.
So, a rich person could buy a piece of art
for $4 million, let it appreciate over a few
years, shop around for a favorable appraisal,
overstate its value, rely on the fact that
the IRS only audits a tiny percentage of pieces,
donate the art $10 million, and they’ll
have already broken even.
It doesn’t take much for the percentage
a wealthy person will save in taxes to eclipse
their original purchase price.
As a cherry on top, of course, the presence
of an artist’s work in a museum is known
to inflate the value of their other art, so
if a wealthy person owns a collection of a
given artist’s work, as is common, donations
earn them further money through the effect
it has on the rest of their collection.
In aggregate, the situation is this: art is
a highly exploitable market.
It was created by rich people, for rich people,
so it suits their needs.
Whether its tax avoidance, money laundering,
or simple price-fixing, the art market enables
all.
Despite this, it’s almost entirely unregulated.
There are no official records of who owns
what or how much they paid, so it’s nearly
impossible to prove any malpractice in the
market.
It’s a largely lawless market, except for
the simple, practical rule that you must be
able to spend millions to enter it.
So, who loses out?
Well, for one, artists.
Rich people use artwork like trading cards—coveting
a select few for arbitrary reasons—which
excludes those who are unable to persuade
the gatekeepers of their value—those who
don’t fit the galleries’ vision of a marketable
artist.
Art is no longer an exercise of skill, it’s
one of branding.
Warhol’s are like Supreme, but for the wealthiest
percent of a percent.
Who also loses out is us: everyone who is
unable to access this exclusive market by
sinking millions of dollars into a single,
volatile investment.
We lose out because we can’t conduct the
same financial wizardry as those who walk
through Sotheby’s doors.
We can access the stock market, where tax
avoidance, money laundering, and price-fixing
are heavily regulated and monitored, but not
this market, where these ruses go largely
unnoticed.
The reality is that any market can be exploited,
which is why markets are regulated.
The difference here is that art is a unique
market where individual players have both
the influence to manipulate the market, and
the influence to keep the market manipulatable.
Everything you’ve heard so far is about
the largely legal malpractice the art market
enables, but it also makes illegal actions
like money laundering and forgery strikingly
easy.
As much as I wanted to talk about that, as
it’s fascinating, this video is already
far too long.
Therefore, as usual, I made an exclusive Nebula
companion video diving deeper into that subject
for those who found this video particularly
interesting.
I was able to do that because Nebula, unlike
YouTube, has no algorithm to punish me for
publishing a video that only the most engaged
viewers are going to be interested in.
Nebula was founded and is owned by creators,
so it’s made to be the best home to our
content, with no ads and a financial model
that enables exclusive companion videos and
big-budget Nebula Originals.
We’ve also made sure that Nebula is the
absolute best deal in the streaming world
by partnering with CuriosityStream.
Now, when you sign up for any subscription
at CuriosityStream.com/Wendover, you get access
to Nebula too.
That means, for the cost of a fancy cheeseburger,
less than $15 a year, you can watch all of
Nebula, and all of CuriosityStream, including
Heval—their first ever Original feature
film, telling the true story a famed British
actor who dropped everything to join the fight
against ISIS in Syria.
Considering you get both Nebula and CuriosityStream
for a year for what you pay for a month of
other streaming services, you can tell why
I call it the best deal in streaming, and
even while getting that amazing deal, you’ll
be supporting Wendover and all the other independent
Nebula creators.
So, click the button on-screen or head to
CuriosityStream.com/Wendover to sign up for
the bundle deal today.